I guess just to start walk start off
with with seeds for Google glass and
this movie for computer screens what
sort of sort of begat this sort of
fascination with tech technology you
know I think tech came second and making
something that was different came first
you know I've always you know wanted to
you know as inspiring as like an
up-and-coming filmmaker I always was
like I shouldn't be making things that
everybody's making I'll never noticed
you know like in like there's a very
there's a little bit of strategy there
you know but like for us it was like
taking these opportunities that no one
thought was possible and still telling a
very emotional story with them we
thought was a very cool challenge that
would not only be what we want to do
which is tell a story but do it in a way
that would hopefully kind of give us
another opportunity to make something
else again because you know whether it
was a Google glass video or slideshows
for Google commercials you know there's
always some weird hook to what we were
doing and searching is no different sure
how much of your life do you find sort
of centered around technology um I would
say honestly no more than the next
person I just feel like I've developed a
very odd unique ability to frame them in
a way within a narrative do you feel
like technology is sort of a positive or
negative thing do you have any sort of
ah yes I think it is both and I think
people only focus on the negative
usually mm-hmm what is positive about
technology I mean I think while it has
the ability to make us obsessed with our
phones and alienate us it also has the
potential to make us love connect and
laugh and and do a lot of things like
the people who actually make check the
engineers their intentions are so good
you know they're like they're not but
like media always says hide your kids
hide you know like it's like we have a
certain like rapport about it that we
wanted to kind of like hopefully just
illuminate and kind of make show more
holistically where do you see technology
going in sort of the not-too-distant
future do you think about that kind of
thing yeah I think about how one thing
that I think about is is that like you
know we have tech companies right now
but I was thinking like man and in the
future there's gonna be no such thing as
a tech company because every company no
matter what it does is gonna be a tech
company you know I think like it's just
it's just like it's an aspect of our
life that it feels like a thing now but
at one point it's not going to be a
thing it's gonna be ubiquitous and this
is just the way we're all gonna live so
much of the film is about sort of the
duality between who you are in real life
versus who you are on a screen does that
does that ring true for yourself is that
sort of yeah everyone likes to say no
you know yeah sure I mean I you know I
think online is a very obviously curated
a specific version of yourself and and I
think that's definitely the movie tries
to talk a little bit about that duality
who are you on screen versus in real
life TV ah you know and rely on screen
I'm you know charming cute very
intelligent very awesome real life I
find myself charming cute intelligent
also no I I don't know I I don't know I
think I feel like my facebook is sort of
become a LinkedIn as of late and my
twitter has become my inner thoughts and
my instagram has become the most
accurate version of my life writing to
the tech how does that affect sort of
the writing process for the screenplay
you know our objective from day one has
been to take a very classic structure in
a classic thriller format and just adapt
it to take place on a screen so Arverne
we never wanted to make a screen movie
we wanted to make a normal movie that
was just happen to take place on screens
so the first thing that we did was
structure this story very classically
like a normal movie every scene had to
have a live-action counterpart you know
in an in a normal movie and basically
then we studied every button on a
computer screen and figured like what is
the best button that we can press that
would convey the right emotion there's
like that first then that do you find
buttons on computers have sort of an
intrinsic emotional value not inherently
but there is a way to do it and that's
something that I learned at Google is
like you can get a lot of emotion out of
a place that you never thought you could
sir and that honestly has been kind of a
weird theme in my life as far as using
tech to tell stories what uh what what
in particular what sort of buttons can
you sort of place emotions I think the
first thing that comes to my mind is
like emptying trash you know like I
think like if you put the right thing in
the trash can and then you empty that
like there's a very very sad feeling
about it or is there something that's
you're letting go of something you know
and like I think that can convey emotion
if you put it in the right context it
happens at a moment in the film very
specific moment in the film you know
whether you type something in backspace
it you know our idea of changing a
period to an exclamation mark back to a
period at the end of a sentence like
what does that convey you know I think
like there are these little kind of
moments that we that trude's that we all
live online that I think can be
exploited to a very cinematic canvas
what sort of mystery films or thrillers
did you look to when you were sort of
coming up with everything
Heol missing kids story ransom kids
story abducted kids story you know I
didn't figuring out who did it kids
story like ransom gone girl prisoners
making a murder we watch true crime
stories serial we listen to the podcast
basically anything that involves
somebody kind of going away for some
weird situation we were like let's study
it what do you take away from those
films man they're so good how are we
ever gonna do that how are we ever gonna
do that no I think I think oftentimes
for us it was it was how to set up a
good red herring how to give clues in
front of people's face and never feel
like you were giving clues to them
that's one of the best things I think
about searching is that like the movie
has a very very strong twist and like a
like a whodunit at the end of it but
like and the clues to that are peppered
everywhere and I think we learned how to
pepper those clues by watching the
better films I was gonna ask when you're
writing a mystery do you start with the
ending sort of the whodunit and the why
and then work your way back or is that
sort of something that develops well we
know the ending ending we know the who
and and the main whys like a lot of
other things you're oftentimes you're
going both directions you know like you
want to create something that is just
because you know the answer at the end
doesn't mean it's always gonna lead to
the most thrilling left to right watch
we need something that is most
importantly thrilling left to right so
we're both like answering things here
and creating things here that we need to
answer over here you know it's a weird
little mix and match but I think what
ends up coming out is a story that is
very up and down to us attorney how
similar was the first draft to sort of
very very similar we ended up I think
cutting one scene from it that we didn't
need the only changes to the movie were
the stuff that we had to add to the side
you know like in all of the lines of
text that weren't part of the screenplay
but it surprisingly like we'd there's
our screenplays if you read it now it's
like you're not gonna really notice a
difference given the content of the
movie is there room to change on set or
is it sort of strict by the book at that
point we wanted to stay by the book
onset you know me we had really really
this movie is a lot about planning and
doing things methodically and like you
know understanding what the final
product a year and a half later is gonna
look like a year and a half before and
we needed to kind of stay within those
parameters so a lot of set is like
executing a version of this movie that
we aren't in you in our head do you see
yourself as a filmmaker continuing to
sort of use technology in your movies
that sort of a basis or absolutely not
you know I think this is a last screen
movie that we're making I think
technology yeah we I think I found it I
think I'm I there's lessons here that I
think I can absolutely use when
technology plays a role in other
narratives that I really want to kind of
use and in our next film I think I'll
probably maybe do a sequence like this
but like there's this is just a way of
telling a story it's not the story
itself
you